just a heads up guys I'm in the process
of moving and while I'm in the process
of moving houses my local movie theater
didn't get the movie the World's End so
I need to go find a movie theater that
got it and watch it it'll be a little
delayed on that one but in the meantime
let's review a movie that apparently
came out in 2011
you're so you're next as a slasher flick
home invasion movie that was made in
2011 and now it's getting a wider
release and everyone gets to watch and
enjoy a family getting completely
slaughtered but this is a home invasion
movie and it was made on a budget of
about 5 bucks which makes sense someone
wants to make a movie they don't have a
budget for it let's just have a lot of
people die for the most part this movies
pretty cliche I mean the acting is
shitty it's terrible you're watching the
setup and you're like I don't care about
the family they're acting certainly
doesn't make me care about them anymore
then you start watching this family
getting brutally slaughtered by these
guys wearing Cooney Mitsu masks from
Tekken you're like didn't care before
don't care now this family's just
getting wasted you have no idea why but
you're just watching it because that's
the movie by the end of the movie the
movie ended and I walked out going i
surprisingly liked it it was weird that
I went from this is [ __ ] to know who
wasn't bad when I say by the end of this
movie I really liked it I mean the
second half of the movie up until the
last frame the last thing in the movie
happens and I was like I like that too
but there are simple reasons why the
movie ended up being enjoyable first of
all the main chick is badass
you know those slasher flicks that try
to make the main chick badass but in the
end you have this chick who is clearly
not badass and she's a bad actor but she
wins in the end because the script says
she's badass but you don't buy any of it
in this one the main chick is actually
badass you feel like she could kick my
ass I know that I don't know that that's
saying much but I'm just saying you walk
away going I wouldn't [ __ ] with her for
all intents and purposes she carries
this entire movie the movie tries to
surprise you by throwing curveballs into
the mix you girls like ooh here's a
twist here there's gonna be a twist here
but you see it all coming and I'll tell
you what this movie is this is a
grindhouse movie you know that movie
grindhouse by Robert Rodriguez and
Quentin Tarantino you had those fake
trailers in the middle and you had
machete spawned off of that this could
have been one of those trailers and now
it's made into a movie I guarantee you
this when you see TV spots for this
movie's gonna be like Fangoria praises
not the least bit surprised I'm telling
it now there's a fair amount of gore and
blood in this movie but it's like it's
horror movie blood where it's thicker
than real blood because it's corn syrup
and dye you can just tell so your next
is not breaking any ground it's not like
you're gonna walk out of this movie be
like Oh finally a concept I've never
seen before but if you're a Gore movie
fan you dig movies like this and jump
scares don't bother you there are a lot
of jump scares in this movie you're
going to have a fun time with your next
I will say for what it was which is
funny because this is the second movie
in a row when I write it up I don't like
for
it was but for what it was your next is
a good time no alcohol required side
note what is it with horror movies like
this where they rip out a piece of
shrapnel out of their skin and it sounds
like Jabba the Hutt's tongue you're like
your stupid lasagna it's all like ah
just over the top it just makes me
hungry alright so the summer movie
season is more or less over at this
point what did you think what was your
favorite summer movie what was your
least favorite summer movie whatever
they are comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more